tenemos aquí un cuadrado y todos los
lados de este cuadrado tienen longitud x
en este vídeo veremos si el perímetro
del cuadrado es proporcional a la
longitud de un lado del cuadrado
entonces pensemos en esto un poco lo que
haré es dibujar una tabla y en esta
tabla vamos a tener tres columnas
entonces pongo en esta tabla tres
columnas y en la primera columna
pensaremos en la longitud de los lados
del cuadrado que cada uno mide x
entonces longitud de un lado
y sabemos que mide x entonces en la
siguiente columna pensaremos en el
perímetro en esta columna pensaremos en
el perímetro del cuadrado que es el
perímetro el perímetro es la suma de las
longitudes de los lados del cuadrado
entonces tenemos que el perímetro en un
cuadrado es igual a x + x + x + x eso es
igual a 4 x 4 x muy bien ahora para esta
última columna aquí pensaremos en la
razón la razón entre el perímetro y la
longitud de un lado entonces tenemos
perímetro / longitud
un lado muy bien ahora veamos cuando la
longitud de un lado es igual a 1 cuánto
será el perímetro será 4 por 1 eso es
igual a 11 11 será 4 entonces tenemos 4
y cuál será la razón la razón será 4
sobre 1 eso es igual a 4
ahora qué pasará cuando la longitud de
un lado es igual a 2 entonces cuando
mide 2 el perímetro será igual a 22 22
eso será igual a 4 por 28 entonces
tenemos que el perímetro es igual a 8 y
la razón será igual a 8 sobre 28 sobre 2
eso es igual a 4 entonces creo que
empezamos a ver un patrón aquí la razón
entre el perímetro y la longitud de un
lado parece que siempre es 4 y podemos
seguir por ejemplo si la longitud de un
lado mide 3 el perímetro será igual a 4
por 3 esos 12 y las razones 12 entre 3
eso es igual a 4 ahora no crees que esto
es magia porque para averiguar el
perímetro simplemente estamos
multiplicando lo que mide la longitud de
un lado por 4 entonces la razón entre el
perímetro y la longitud de un lado
siempre será igual a 4 x entre x si un
lado mide x y eso siempre es igual a 4
entonces vemos que tenemos una relación
proporcional la razón entre el perímetro
y la longitud de un lado siempre será
igual a 4 o podríamos decir lo siguiente
dado que esta tabla no fue necesaria
pero queda un poco más claro si lo
hacemos podemos decir que el perímetro
el perímetro es igual a 4 por la
longitud de un lado entonces el
perímetro es igual a 4 por la longitud
de un lado y queda claro que es una
relación proporcional el perímetro es
igual a una constante que multiplica a
la longitud de un lado del cuadrado o el
perímetro dividido entre la longitud de
un lado es siempre igual a 4 por lo
tanto en definitiva es una relación
proporcional entre la longitud de un
lado del cuadrado y el perímetro del
cuadrado y bueno terminamos